bonjour à tous aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous proposer un petit peu de légèreté
en vous parlant de la série de warda
vision nous n'en avons toujours pas
parler et pourtant il ya pas mal de
choses à dire notamment par rapport au
film de black widow qui était censée
ouvrir la phase 4 ce sera finalement au
loin de la vision qui aura ce rôle
puisque la série est prévu normalement
pour janvier 2021 si tout se passe bien
évidemment et première particularité
cette série est en quelque sorte un test
pour les studios marvel car pour la
première fois nous sommes face à une
série marvel qui possède un rôle
normalement 10 principales ce que je
veux dire c'est que oui il existe déjà
des séries en rapport avec le mc eu
comme à john sauf shield ou agents
carter etc
mais ces séries possède un rôle bien
plus secondaires nous ne sommes pas du
tout obligé de les voir pour assimiler
le mc eu ses intrigues ces détails là
que ce soit au rwanda vision la série
law qui ou celle avec kate bishop et les
suivantes
elles ont toutes un rôle principal pour
la saga
c'est pourquoi je parle de séries test
ou nda vision est censé déboucher sur le
film de doctor strange de multivers of
madness et donc nous apporter du
contexte des détails et du contenu dont
il n'y aura pas besoin de montrer pour
le film mais encore une fois c'est assez
particulier car cette série comme les
autres est censé être importante pour le
mc eu mais c'est un terrain nouveau pour
eux les films resteront toujours
beaucoup plus principaux alors nous
sommes en droit de nous demander si une
série comme one la vision composée de
seulement six épisodes et qui sert à
introduire docteur strange 2 n'a pas un
rôle au final assez secondaire comme une
version longue d'un film je ne sais pas
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire pointe
sa vision a pour rôle d'apporter du
contexte des justifications et du pseudo
contenu pour enrichir la saga est donc
le film de doctor strange 2 comme par
exemple la folie entre guillemets de
wendat qui sera un axe principal de
doctor strange 2 one la vision
permettrait de mettre en place tout ça
c'est ça l'utilité de la série en gros
bref mais pour bien parler tout ça il
faut qu'on entre dans le détail et
notamment par rapport au trailer
partager le contexte post in game et
l'avenir du hem cellule
tout d'abord il y a quelque chose qui
pour moi est hyper important à souligner
et qui justifient beaucoup de choses
pour la série one la vision se passe
tout d'abord après avengers endgame je
pense que vous le savez tous et rwanda
contrairement aux autres héros comme
antoine qui à cassis la guêpe enquête
serra ou encore les gardiens de la
galaxie qui sont un groupe est bien
rwanda elle est seule dans avengers
endgame rwanda est ultra puissante car
elle souffre elle est en colère après la
noce et cela a été confirmé par les
scénaristes du film la puissance de
wendat dépend de ses émotions après une
game nous la retrouvons aux côtés de
clint parlant de la perte de natacha et
visions et semble apaisée et pourtant
wendat est seul et la solitude pour ce
genre de personnage n'est pas du tout
bénéfique vous allez comprendre
si nous passons sur le trailer plusieurs
choses interpelle énormément tout
d'abord le cas de vision vision est
vivant dans la série et en plus avec la
gemme de l'esprit est là c'est un gros
problème c'est tout bonnement impossible
en fait puisque vision est mort
effectivement et surtout les gem sont
impossible à retrouver surtout pour
quelqu'un comme moi mme da pareil pour
la présence des enfants du rwanda qui
sont effectivement une référence pour
les comics mais en termes de cohérence
et de temps pour la série ou honda ne
peut pas avoir le temps d'engendrer des
enfants ce qui veut dire qu'on est bien
deux ans après une game et c'est
impossible puisque la série sert
simplement d'introduction pour doctor
strange 2 on peut pas se projeter aussi
loin dans le temps avec un premier pas
pour la phase iv également pour le
changement de réalité en quelques
secondes ou tout simplement le
changement de physique de vision en un
temps éclair alors que ce dernier a
besoin d'évoluer dans son environnement
et bien la raison est simple par rapport
à ce que nous savons du futur de ouenza
lé l'avenger cela plus puissante et
certainement une énorme menace pour
l'avenir de la saga
cette dernière a la possibilité de
modifier la réalité voire d'en créer une
nouvelle
et comme le démontre le plan avec monica
rambo dont nous allons parler juste
après brenda se trouve dans une fosse
ville surveillé par les autorités que
beaucoup suspectent être le sword
c'est là que le paramètre solitude entre
en jeu wendat s'est créé une sorte de
bulle une ville qui serait totalement
issue de sa création et de son esprit
que la police surveillaient de loin
c'est un fait tout ce que nous voyons
dans le trailer est fake et n'existe pas
réellement
cependant plusieurs questions s'imposent
déjà vision bien que son cas soit
impossible ce dernier est bel et bien
mort
et pourtant en bas il ne semble pas si
irréel que ça
comme nous le montre le passage du
trailer ou vision parle avec le
personnage du nom d'agnès jouée par
catherine anne
cette dernière lui révèle que vision est
normalement mort et le plan ou vision
s'envole au dessus de la ville révèle
encore plus l'état d'esprit du
personnage comme si il comprenait que la
ville n'était pas normal est pire que sa
vision est normalement un mari aimant un
citoyen lambda dans wendat vision et non
une entité qui plane au dessus de la
ville par simple plaisir entre
guillemets surtout qu'il doit rester
anonyme pour la crédibilité du couple
donc voilà ce plan révèle pour moi le
moment où vision va comprendre la
supercherie
sauf que le problème c'est qu'il n'est
pas vision le vrai vision est mort
durant la guerre dont le wac en dha
c'est ça qui est troublant deux options
sont possibles pour moi soit il est une
pure création de wendat qui a donc une
conscience et serait une sorte de
frankenstein
soit il est un prototype créé par les
gens qui surveille rwanda et qui serait
enjolivé par son esprit et la réalité
créée par la rrq protagonistes
bon c'est peut-être un petit peu
farfelue mais je n'ai pas vraiment de
réponse pour le moment pour en revenir
aux personnages d'agnès elle est
présente dans chaque époque on voyagera
au rwanda et visions et est considérée
comme une voisine un peu trop présente
quoi si nous voulons une explication ce
personnage pourrait être une taupe du
côté de la police ou soit de quelqu'un
contre la police je ne sais pas trop
mais elle ne fait pas partie de la
réalité de wendat elle s'est introduite
c'est certain et là où je me pose
question c'est qu'elle semble se faire
réveiller par vision pile au moment où
ce dernier semble prendre conscience de
certaines choses sur là où ils se
trouvent
c'est pourquoi elle semble surprise de
voir vision car il est normalement mort
et ce qui me perturbe encore plus et son
rire alors oui c'est un petit peu idiot
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi son rire me
donne le message d'une bourde en mode
non mais façon de parler vous n'êtes pas
vraiment mort comme s'il ne fallait pas
qu'elle révèle certaines choses bref
nous devons maintenant parler de la
présence de monica rambo et là je vais
vous conter mon idée la plus personnelle
concernant la série par rapport au
pourquoi du comment au rwanda se
retrouve dans sa réalité dans sa bulle
way comme diam's si les personnes qui
sont en charge de surveiller la ville et
donc wendat sont bel et bien le sort de
rien ne nous permet de le confirmer pour
le moment mais admettons cela veut donc
dire que rwanda pourrait servir à un
projet ou bien que quelque chose ne va
pas avec elle
le problème est qu'au rwanda est une
valeur sûre nommé dans la saga et qui
connaît nick fury et là ça me pose
problème
je ne vois pas nick fiori et donc le
sort de fer de luanda une arme et tester
des choses par le biais de ses pouvoirs
pour moi il est surtout un problème en
fait avec wendat je vous parlais de
solitude et nous semblons être dans une
ville contrôlée par wendat donc ce qui
veut dire qu'il ne lui arrive que des
choses heureuses normalement entre
guillemets et bien wendat serait dans
une sorte de prison ou bâtir et donc
dans le déni de la réalité une réalité
où elle est seule puisque wendat est
suspecté de devenir folle et une grande
menace pour l'avenir du monde
et des avengers il se pourrait qu'elle
était enfermée dans sa propre réalité
avec que des choses qu'elle aime pour
éviter qu'elle ne fasse une catastrophe
c'est là que monica rambo semble
intervenir monica rambo est la fille de
maria la meilleure amie de captain
marvel nous avons eu l'occasion de la
voir dans le film de ladite héroïne dans
les comics monica possède des pouvoirs
en rapport avec l'énergie un petit peu à
la manière de carole c'est pourquoi elle
se ferait également appelé captain
marvel à ses débuts mais bref là n'est
pas la question
cette dernière se fait expulser de la
ville et pas de n'importe quelle manière
cette dernière se fait expulser
directement par rwanda comme le démontre
la traînée rouge qui dans la direction
artistique de marvel faire référence au
pouvoir de wang si monica se fait
expulser je vois l'explication pour moi
quel est l'élément perturbateur pour la
protagoniste qui en s'infiltrant dans la
fosse ville voudraient réveiller au
rwanda de sa prison sauf qu'évidemment
cela ne plairait pas la jeune femme qui
la combattre est immédiatement le plus
intéressant avec monica et que dans les
comics elle aurait apparemment un
problème avec ses pouvoirs et devinez
qui c'est docteur strange qui réussira à
lui venir en aide
jobs dans la construction nous savons
que la fin de la série ne sera pas
forcément heureuse et nous sommes plutôt
sur le schéma contraire la vie du rwanda
nous sera montrée comme palpitante et
heureuse avant que des éléments
perturbateurs vienne interrompre sa
fausse vie sauf que c'est comme pour le
mythe du réveil d'un somnambule c'est
comme si au rwanda dormait éveillé et
que certains aimeraient la réveiller
sauf qu'évidemment le réveil ne se fera
pas en douceur comme le démontre monica
rambo un retour à la réalité pour rwanda
sera forcément brutale et expliquerait
le début de sa colère de sa folie étant
un préquel à dr strange 2 je suis
certain que la fin de la série
terminerai sur le sort c'est suprême et
qui sait il est possible que monica soit
le lien entre luanda et strange est que
justement elle le met au courant comme
dernier recours
le seul qui pourrait sauver et lui
enseigner la maîtrise de ses pouvoirs
dans tous les cas la série sera
intéressante car techniquement il n'y
aura pas vraiment de méchant ce serait
même plutôt ou honda qui serait à la
fois le personnage principal mais
également l'antagoniste de sa propre
histoire
enfin voilà j'espère que ma vidéo vous
aura plu et évidemment je n'affirme rien
tout provient de ma tête et mes pensées
en vrai j'ai plutôt hâte de voir cette
petite sitcom qui wendat vision je pense
pas que ce sera quelque chose
d'incroyable non plus mais je pense que
ça risque vraiment d'être intéressant
pour enrichir l'univers et c'est un bon
préquelle à dr strange de jeu profite de
vous avoir pour ceux qui auraient
regardé la vidéo jusqu'au bout pour vous
orienter vers mon dernier trois théories
qui est sur final fantasy 7 remake c'est
un énorme projet qui est très important
pour moi et où je vous livre toutes ma
passion sur cet univers
j'ai vraiment voulu maîtriser
sujet sur le bout des doigts et vous
proposer une immersion totale dans cet
univers cette saga que je chéris temps
bref c'était argot rock n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à la chaîne a laissé un
petit pouce bleu un petit commentaire
car c'est un énorme soutien pour moi et
puis voilà que le 'lion' art soit avec
vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]